- Do you know what it feels
like to be 26 years old,
have people that you
went to high school with
come to your liquor store,
look you dead in the
face as they pulled up
in their BMW and say,
"Oh, you work for your dad?"
And then you ring them up
on their case of champagne
and you bring it out
to their car and put it
in their trunk and they look
you in the face with pity?
I lived that life.
And the way I took that scene was,
"I'll see you in 10 years, motherfucker!"
(energetic rock music)
(dramatic music)
You know, it's funnier.
I was driving here this morning,
I was like, "What do I want to get off?
"What do I want to make sure they know."
The number one thing if
I leave this morning,
that I hope, is for people to realize
how much leverage they have.
How you, just like weight room and film,
you got to put in work
to get what you want
and how, what social
media and the internet
have done has given
you so much opportunity
to take advantage of who you engage with
around what you want.
I think the biggest
vulnerability to this room,
including the coaches, and
us old guys is patience.
I wish, the coaches over here,
knew how young they were.
Watching 30, 40, 50 year-olds
completely confused by
the context of time,
is one of the most fascinating
things I see in our society.
Like, people always come
up to me and they're like,
"Gary, when are you
going to buy the Jets?"
and I'm like, "25 years,"
and they get sad as fuck.
Like, they think I, they like
want me to have it tomorrow.
There was a really famous
basketball college team,
Loyola Marymount.
Every time I think about that team,
it's how I think about my life
and how I think about
myself as an entrepreneur.
They will win college basketball games
like 147 to 132.
They would just run and shoot.
They were just, (exhales)
they just pushed it.
Their games were crazy and
that's how I think about life.
I think too many people
are playing defense.
And I'm out here trying to win 149 to 146.
Offense.
Because once you stop hearing judgment,
and you're not actually worried about
what people have to say,
you can just go fast.
Judgment is the only thing I promise you
that you'll have for
the rest of your life.
(upbeat trance music)
I watch you from afar, I'm like,
that's really good parenting,
really good DNA, and
really good circumstance.
because that kid, is not insecure.
We have insecure--
- [Man] Not anymore.
- Well, that's right.
Truly, truly one of my favorite people.
Give some love to K. Love.
- One tough S.O.B, baby.
- Tag it.
(inspirational music)
- Oh, Gary, I'm so emotional.
- It's so funny that the
alien thing just happened
kind of organic.
- Yeah, it's funny.
- There's more gray in my opinion.
Do you believe in aliens?
Straight up!
- Uh, yes.
- Yeah, I'm gonna really miss you.
- Yeah, I'm gonna miss you too.
I'm gonna miss this company.
- Are we trying to do an episode
about staying in together?
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and is is episode 320
of the Ask Gary Vee Show
and this is a very exciting episode
because the person that will
be dialing the questions
and getting to the
questions today is India,
our very own India, who's on her last day
after seven years at VaynerMedia.
Fun fact for a lot of you that don't know,
India was a superstar.
You know how sometimes, the like,
you know how, like, Ari
Gold actually became
the star of Entourage, but
that wasn't the purpose.
There was absolutely a time in 2016?
- 16 I think.
In 2016 where India was my
main co-host of the show
when it was a completely call-in show
or take questions from the internet show.
And, you know, the reason I
had to get her off the show
was it became clear to me that
she'd become bigger than me,
and I wasn't really willing
to deal with that, you know.
When you're like 54, you're gonna have
like, fun things to say
at like dinner parties.
- Yeah, totally! Absolutely
- And people aren't gonna believe you
and you're gonna have to like, pull it up.
- No really, I did this.
Yeah, people don't even now.
Just like, I had a couple of
like, informational interviews
and they're like, "Oh,
what have you been doing?"
I've been here for like, seven years.
I'm like, "So much, including
like, this show I did,
with, like, the CEO Gary,
and they're like, "What?"
I'm like, "Yeah, that's
true, like, we just did it,"
you know.
- Like, really good!
- Yeah!
So that's been awesome too.
Just to have that
experience to talk about.
And like, everyone loves you
when I bring you up, you know.
So, like, that's just great for me.
I'm like, "I don't care."
- Well, that's where I
really want you to lean in.
- Okay.
- Like, I am ready to,
like, get a phone call
in the middle of a meeting
and it's your phone number.
- Yeah.
- And I'm assuming you
beat me at that moment,
for, like, whatever interview
or whatever you're in
and I'm gonna pick it up and be like,
"No Rick,
(India laughs)
like, you should hire her!"
- Yeah, fuck Rick. He's
always the one you go for.
- Rick and Sally.
- Rick and Sally, yeah.
- Yeah, I really appreciate that.
- Hey Cynthia.
- [Cynthia] Yeah?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Cynthia] Hi!
- Hi, I was just walking by.
I'm actually running out of the building,
but I saw Andrew on the phone and I said,
"Whoever you're talking to on
the phone, I wanna say hello."
And then he said, "She'd
flip $4,000 stuff."
And then I said, "I
really wanna say hello."
- [Cynthia] Oh (laughs) hello!
- Hello, I really really have to run.
I'm super late, but I wanted to say hi,
thank you for watching my content.
- [Cynthia] Oh, Absolutely!
I haven't been watching
it, but all I needed
was that little push and I actually watch
some of your YouTube,
and they were inspiring,
and it's gotten me that far.
So I'm like, "Wow, this is real!"
- [Gary] It's fuckin' pouring.
(man mumbles)
That's awesome.
All right, do we have an umbrella?
- Uh, we do.
(Gary laughs)
That we do.
- [Gary] Oh no.
What the fuck Drock?
- All right, ready?
- All right, let's go.
- [Man] Love you!
- [Gary] We're in it Jason!
(peaceful electronic music)
- [Sheamus] Star Celtic
Warrior Sheamus here.
My question for Gary would
be, Gary, as the owner
of Celtic Warrior
Workout's YouTube channel,
someone like you is on the
grind minimum 18 hours a day.
- [Gary] I'm here!
I'm in my home!
The Jet's facility. What up Jets?
Yo Sam, Darnell, Jamal. If
you're watching, come through.
I'm judging this shark tank
like business challenge.
I'm fuckin' home!
New York Jets baby!
Fuckin' home!
(relaxed hip-hop music)
- Hey, I told them I watched.
My kids were gonna play there
the other day while I got in a fall
watching this guy, and you come over.
I'm like, "I know that guy."
I'm like,
- That's awesome.
My son's watch you
all the time.
- Thank you very much.
- So, I'd love to take a picture with you.
- Let's do it. Well actually,
let's do it even better.
What's their names?
(woman exclaims in excitement)
- Thomas, Robert, Anthony.
- Tom, Robert, Anthony
listen. I'm here with pops.
I have no idea why the
fuck you guys aren't here.
But were hustling, we're best friends now,
and I can't wait to meet you guys.
- That's awesome.
- I'm sure they'll love that.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you. That's Great
- Yeah, real pleasure.
Nice to see ya.
Look this is America, small businesses,
and mainstream businesses,
and entrepreneurs
drive this economy.
It's black and white data.
Without these small
businesses, the whole machine
of this great country doesn't play out.
And so, coming from a
small business environment,
being an investor in small businesses,
being an entrepreneur, I
mean, this is home for me.
(relaxed hip-hop music)
- Hey vlog.
(laughing)
- [Cameraman] Cut.
- Cool, and can I throw this--
- What, am I 15 behind?
22 behind?
- We'll see what's going on.
- Oh, 10.
- [Man] Got a new one every month.
- I added buffers. (laughs)
This is casual.
- Was I, yesterday like, wait a minute,
this wasn't the one where I promised you
I was done at 3 pm?
- [Woman] Yes, of course.
- [Man] You started.
- [Gary] Jason.
- [Jason] Yep?
- [Gary] Not you.
- [Jason] Oh.
- [Gary] I have a call.
- [Man] You right.
- Usually, it's really devastating
for everybody around me.
(laughing)
(relaxed hip-hop music)